Tischtennis spielen oder Billard,
danach ins Fitnessstudio
und anschließend ins Café, bevor es wieder
an die Arbeit geht.
Um gute Leute zu halten, lassen sich die
Firmen so einiges einfallen.
Vor allem Kreativunternehmen, die auf
die Ideen ihrer Mitarbeiter angewiesen sind,
müssen auch ein inspirierendes
Umfeld bieten.
Viele Start-ups arbeiten in
Gemeinschaftsbüros,
die eher einem Loft ähneln.
Ich frage mich: Was macht Menschen
im Büro kreativ?
Welche Umgebung motiviert sie?
Am Fraunhofer-Institut treffe ich
Wissenschaftler,
die dazu Studien gemacht haben.
Ja, Herr Rief, was glauben Sie denn?
Man muss raus können, ich muss
Neues sehen, Neues sehen,
aber auch auf neue Menschen treffen,
des … wir haben …
wir konnten eigentlich auch sehen, dass
mit relativ wenig,
so mit 10, 15 Prozent Abwesenheit
vom Arbeitsplatz,
also dass da tatsächlich die
Ideen ansteigen,
die [ich] dann wieder mit zurückbringe.
Die Büros am Institut sind so gestaltet,
wie es laut Forschungsergebnissen ideal ist.
Die einzelnen Etagen sind über ein
offenes Treppenhaus verbunden –
das soll für mehr Kommunikation sorgen.
Aber wer konzentriert arbeiten will,
der kann sich auch zurückziehen.
Raumteiler sollen den Schall dämpfen.
Es gibt keine festen Arbeitsplätze, jeder
sucht sich jeden Tag einen neuen Ort.
Viel Abwechslung ist also wichtig,
und die Büroumgebung sollte sich
meinen Bedürfnissen anpassen.
Für Unternehmen, die ihre Büros nach
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
einrichten wollen, wurde eine 3-D-Software
entwickelt,
mit der sich Räume virtuell begehen lassen.
Gute Idee, so kann man schon vorher
testen, ob man sich wohlfühlt.
Microsoft hat zum Beispiel seine
Deutschlandzentrale
zusammen mit dem Fraunhofer-Institut
gestaltet.
Auch die Wirkung von Licht wird erforscht.
In diesem Besprechungsraum lässt
sich Tageslicht simulieren –
inklusive Sonnenuntergang.
Die Arbeitswelt verändert sich.
Das haben auch große Konzerne erkannt,
wie der Sportartikelhersteller Puma.
Das Durchschnittsalter der Mitarbeiter
liegt hier bei 33 Jahren.
Junge Leute aus aller Welt kommen nach
Herzogenaurach in die deutsche Provinz –
auch wegen der lockeren Arbeitsatmosphäre.
Die neuen Büros wurden in Zusammenarbeit
mit Designern gestaltet.
Die schlichten Räume sollen ein kreatives
Arbeiten unterstützen.
Mitarbeiter können wählen, ob sie immer
am gleichen Schreibtisch sitzen
oder lieber flexibel arbeiten wollen.
Der Personalchef hat die Mitarbeiter
befragt, wie sie das offene Büro finden,
denn auf Einzelbüros müssen
sie verzichten.
Im Prinzip geht’s um zwei Dinge meistens,
es geht um Blick-
und geht um Geräuschschutz.
Und wenn man diese Maßnahmen
insofern dann auch umsetzt,
auch gut umsetzt, kriegt man eigentlich ’n
sehr positiven Zuspruch,
was jetzt ein Open-Office-Konzept angeht.
Dazu gehört auch der Tischkicker
in der Mittagspause.
Das haben sich die großen Firmen bei
den Start-ups abgeguckt.
Die Schallschutzkabine, die will ich
selbst testen, als Viel-Telefoniererin.
Und dann hab ich mir eine Pause verdient.
Insgesamt einfach mehr Freiräume –
das scheint das Wichtigste zu sein
im neuen Wohlfühl-Büro.